Build up
ah
we made 0a
aa aa
asem
3 I do
n't know Everyone's endless love really continues to experience this house ah jae It gives me a sense of
self.
Aaah er opera tweet wei living and selling important so very ordinary people No. 5 we were moved by the heart wr reading 48w everyone oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
my
1 free first year receiving 1
samsung card ask for a Samsung card
w there's w in the movie erato shovie learning William
Yeokjin with customers  As a customer with a rifle,
where did you go? Really, where did you go with such
an
infantile period?
Hide Give me something to encourage ah
[clap]
[music]
[Music]
[Applause]